Bailey: Okay, so our final
speaker this afternoon
is Kurt Schwehr,
from the University
of New Hampshire.
And Kurt's a proper techie geek.
So it's fitting we
end with one.
But he's involved
in using his skills
in a number of areas,
in planetary--
but, in particular,
ocean data.
And it's that he's going
to be talking about today.
How he's developed uses
of geo special data
in Google's GeoTools.
Schwehr: All right,
thank you.
I want to start off
with a figure,
to remind you all
that New Hampshire
indeed does have a coastline.
We have 17 miles of coast.
We actually do touch the ocean.
Most people don't seem
to realize that.
And I'd also like
to acknowledge my collaborators,
many people at NOAA,
Cornell University,
and the U.S. Coast Guard
have contributed
to the products
that you'll see up here today.
And I want to go back
into the not-too-distant past
and talk a little bit
about where we used to be,
before we had Google Earth
and--and some more tools.
When we were at NASA,
we used to have to spend
huge amounts of money
trying to buy a large SGIs,
keep them running,
and then write
all of our software
on our own.
Just to make this crummy
looking earth that's up here.
And there's no
nice textured background.
It sort of looks
like north America.
And we sort of have
a red blob on there,
and if you click on it,
it pops up
an actually fairly
nice graphic of something,
but there's no way
to scale in between the two,
and handle
all the nice things
that Google Earth
now handles for us
for pretty much free here,
with KML.
And you used to have
to get a van,
and truck it all over to
where you're gonna do your demo.
And today,
we take our laptop, open it up,
and you're good to go.
That's had a dramatic effect
on how we looked at data,
and how much data
we can look at.
I'd like to take
a little bit of a tour
where we went,
and what kinds of things
we're trying to do
to support the mariners,
who are out there
on our waterways,
trying to get commerce
through,
and to keep
our economy running.
My background is
a little bit of geology,
so I want to show you sort of
how I got into Google Earth,
and what we
started looking at at first.
So here's
the Santa Barbara basin,
off of California.
And we started looking
at what we could do
with, say, taking
a journal paper,
and scanning the figures in.
Or using something
like Fledermaus
to generate a 3-D model,
and then slap it in there.
Or actually, just texture your
bathymetry onto the ocean floor,
where we have
a high-resolution survey.
This--in this case,
it's from MBARI's research ship.
And as you go through that,
I started playing
with the idea
of taking each scientist,
and maybe we could build
a Google Earth resume.
So it's a concept of,
for a particular scientist,
where they've been
as they go through their career.
And you can
actually glean a lot
as they go
through the geologic record,
trying to figure out
what's going on.
A lot of insight
comes from what problems
we're looking at,
and when in their career,
and how
that influences things.
If you went back a ways,
you might see the revolution
that occurred
in earth sciences,
where people realized that
plate tectonics is a real thing.
It was a huge change
of thought to people.
And a lot of that is buried
in the literature,
in terms of where
they were looking on the ocean,
and how they looked
at the earth.
They went from an old model
to a brand-new model.
That was a
really radical change.
And so I think, as we dig back
into that--those archives,
we'll start pulling out
more of that,
and really see
a historical change.
Now, to jump into
some of our modern tools
that we're looking at,
and give you a sense
of what we can actually do
for the mariners,
to change their world,
and make it a better place
for them to move out
on the waterways,
and for those
who are managing it,
I used an open source tool,
just to get going.
We took a NOAA chart,
which are the little red lines
you'll see up on the screen.
And on that chart, we've dropped
it on top of Google Earth.
And if you look
at the pier in the middle,
next to the orange arrow,
you'll see a really long pier
next to
a really short red icon--
little iconographic
description of the pier.
Now which one is right?
If you came through
in the middle of the night,
do you want to find out?
So we've been looking at
if you can just drop a chart in,
and do a quick look,
you can catch a lot of errors
that would've been very
difficult to see down the road.
I'll show a couple
more examples of kinds
of surprising things
that we've found,
and how tools like Google Earth
can just pop this right out,
without having to go through
and dig through databases,
and try to look at
Excel spreadsheets
and figure out
what's going on.
Now as these ships
move around,
there's actually a new
technology that's been deployed
for about the last five years.
And it's coming
into more and more use.
And it's called the
Automatic Identification System.
So planes, for a long time,
have had devices
that tell you where they are.
And the FAA can tell you
what ship is where
in the United States.
Well, now we have that
for the maritime world.
So, ships are trying
to put these transponders on.
And they're mainly meant
for collision avoidance,
so instead of just having
to rely on your radar,
you have a device
that actually tells you
who's around you,
and what they're doing.
Now, for us as researchers,
we'd like to see
what the ship's doing,
why are they out there,
why are there problems,
where are there areas
that are working well?
And so what you see up here
is a combination
of a little bit
fancier nautical chart.
Here I've used
the EarthNC charts,
and I've taken a couple layers
out of their tools,
and merged it
with AIS ship tracks
throughout entry
to Delaware Bay.
And you can see that
there's vessels moving all over.
Some are using
the green traffic lanes,
and following the rules
of the road.
They aren't required to.
And then there's other vessels
that are crossing it.
And then there's vessels
that have to wait around
for some reason.
And so we need
to go in there and look at,
as they're out there,
what's delaying these ships,
And how can we optimize
what they are doing,
while keeping them safe?
Now it's not always
safe out there
and things do happen.
So we can use techniques
like this
to look at events,
like the Cosco Busan.
This ship, in 2007, ran into--
or as they call it
in the maritime world--
alighted with a fixed object,
called the
San Francisco Bay Bridge.
And by having the ship
tracking and recorded
by all the transponders,
we can see
what was going on with that.
And the investigators--
I'm not involved in that--
but they can
actually look at these tracks,
and start
to understand what's going on.
And we can provide them
with graphics,
where they can go in
with a time slider,
move things around.
They can remove
all the ships
except for the ships
that they care about.
And start really digging into
why this incident happened.
And hopefully
with those investigations,
they an create new rules
or remove rules
that were causing problems,
to make the waterways
more effective and safe.
And you can kind of combine
that information with things
like in the bottom left,
we have an image
that was captured
by the ship's radar.
And so investigators can
really get a fuller picture
of maritime incidents
as they happen in the waterways
much better than
they ever have in the past.
Now, as a part of that,
in addition to things like AIS,
we also need to get
more sensors out there.
NOAA, the EPA
and other federal agencies
have got a pretty good
infrastructure out there,
but we need more.
We need sensors
that really go in
and tell us what's going on
in the environment.
So here, I've shown you
an example of company
that's trying to push
that innovation curve,
Sensorware Systems.
And they're
trying to place all sorts
of sensors out
in the environment,
and give us tools to be able
to go in and look at this stuff
24-7, 365,
good days or bad days,
and tell us what's going on
out in the environment.
That way, we as scientists
and researchers
can really understand
what it is
that's causing
those trouble spots,
and why things are working the
way they are in the waterways.
If you don't know
what's happening out there,
how are you supposed
to help them out?
Now, one of the things
that we try to do
is once you have an incident,
there's a short time period
where responders have
to get in there
and really start to work with
the local enforcement folks,
and try to get
that environment cleaned up
and restored
back to where it was.
So to give you an example
of some of the things
that we're
seeing in the waterway,
I'm showing you a picture
of a grounding in Alaska.
This could be anywhere
in the United States.
There's a lot of incidents
on the waterways.
It's getting busier out there,
so things do happen.
It's like
being on the highway.
You don't expect
to have an accident,
but every once in a while,
something happens
that may even be
out of your control.
So we've been working
on web interfaces to provide
a consistent environment
for each of ports to have,
that they can call up.
And responders who come
from out of town
may have never been
in this particular area,
they need a consistent view
of what's in the area,
a consistent
set of data products,
and access to the management
plans that have been in place.
So that they can
quickly respond to things
such as oil spills,
where every minute or hour
that you can't get out there
and figure out what to do,
causes you to not be able
to recover as much
of the oil or debris
that's out in your waterways.
So here, for example, we're
showing multibeam bathymetry,
showing super high resolution
features of the waterways.
And this is
Portsmouth, New Hampshire.
And you can see such things
as sand waves
that are just a meter
or two across.
And you combine that
with your roads and highways.
And the icons show you
all of your caches
for your response tools.
This way, the people
that come out on site,
they may not have been
here before,
but they can get going
right away,
and start to figure out
what they need to do
in the first few hours
of a response.
Now, once
you're way past that,
and you've gotten
past your investigations,
such as the Cosco Busan,
the coastguard keeps a database
of incident investigations.
Part of that database sits
inside of a tool,
called MISLE.
and it's the
Marine Information for Safety
and Law Enforcement database.
And part of that--
we have access
to these incidents,
and we can color code them.
Here, I've used the OSHA symbols
for industrial accidents.
Not quite the right icons,
but it gives you a gist
of what's going on
in the waterways.
And you can see
what are the areas
that are having
the most trouble,
and where we need to focus
our research efforts,
to make this
a much more focused research
and find those problems
that need to be addressed.
You can see
that the Gulf Coast
has the majority
of the incidents.
With a fairly good number going
on in our inland waterways.
So those folks refer
to themselves
as "the brown water crowd."
They have plenty of incidents
they need to work on, too.
There's a lot
of tight waterways
and passing arrangements
that are difficult
with these big ships trying
to move our economic resources
up and down
the Mississippi River.
Let's zoom in here.
This is Norfolk, Virginia.
And you can take
a look at their database.
We've started to create tools
that help associate
these together,
without having to dig
into their Oracle database.
So anyone can go in
and associate
a particular incident
with the details
of the accident,
or you can drill down and
get the entire accident report.
And that way,
we can start looking
at what actually happened
to incident.
Is there something
that we can address?
Or is this, say, an act
of nature or a weird occurrence?
Something
that we can't control?
Therefore, there's nothing
we can do about it.
Or can we add a sensor
to help ships out
as they come
into particular areas.
An example
of that might be...
the inland waterways,
some of the locks,
as you approach them,
have really horrible
cross currents
that vary with time.
So can we put sensors
in the water column
that will
tell you the currents
and report that back
to the ships?
Now as mariners
go through the waterways,
they're relying on groups
such as NOAA
to provide them
with the resources
to understand where
they're going.
This is the road atlas
for ships.
And it starts
with field data entry.
There's validation.
And then NOAA produces
what's called the "Coast Pilot."
This is a document that's been
around for a very long time.
Over 100 years.
And it hasn't changed
in 100 years.
So we have
a really excellent tool.
Mariners count on this.
But can we do better
with a geo-spatial tool?
We took a look at LIDAR.
And LIDAR is great.
You can generate thousands
of laser points
ranged into your environment.
And you can look
into buildings, see trees,
all sorts of stuff.
But it generates
a lot of data,
and you're going
to overwhelm your people at--
who are trained mariners
who are not used to dealing
with point clouds--
with data that isn't going
to necessarily help them.
This might be helpful
for a modeler.
And we've looked into what we
can do with producing models
to supplement those that--that
people like Google have created.
And we can
add the waterway critical
to buildings and markers.
So here, we've done
a lighthouse on Cape Cod.
This is Highland Light,
modeled by Christiana.
And in this model, it gives us a
good sense of what's out there.
But unfortunately, if we were
to do all the lights,
and waterway devices that
we wanted to have out there,
it's prohibitively expensive
and time consuming
to model each of these.
It takes us going out to a site,
running around the building,
building a model, validating it,
going through all of our tools,
and dropping it
into sketch up
and placing it
into Google Earth.
The last two steps are easy.
All that leads up to that
is actually fairly challenging
for these
unusually-shaped objects.
It would be nice if all
of our lighthouses were square,
but unfortunately,
they're not.
So we've looked at an approach
of running around with a camera.
And cameras are
getting better every day.
They're adding sensors
that we need.
It used to be that adding a GPS
to a camera was difficult.
Now, you can go to the store,
and you can buy a camera
that has a GPS, and it has a
three-axis magnetic compass--
so you know which way
it's pointed.
Another engineer and I--
Matt--
We went through Boston Harbor
in one day,
and photo surveyed
the entire harbor.
...
But you can go in on one day
and survey an entire harbor.
Now, how can we use that
information to present something
to go along with that text,
to produce a new environment,
that's helpful
for our mariners?
So we've come up with a process.
Collect a whole bunch of photos.
So here's Matt and I
collecting photos in Boston.
You need to match
those photos to features.
You need to crop those photos,
register them, orient them,
and get them
into a database.
And once we have that,
we can try to create interfaces
to these--
this new type of data.
We've been playing with, as
Matt calls it, the multirama.
Where basically, you have
an oriented image slice,
and a render of pics,
which one to do
based on which way
you're looking at it.
The nice thing about this
is unlike a CAD model,
you catch all those features
that cue the mariner
into what to look for.
So if a building
is buried among the trees,
you capture all those trees
that you would
never want to model
in a 3-D world.
It's just too expensive.
So in our lab,
we've gone ahead and prototyped
a little version of this
to see what we might be.
You're welcome to download it
and give it a try.
We're always looking
for feedback.
We've got some features
that we haven't figured out
how to do
in Google Earth yet.
As you move around this world,
you'll see pictures moving--
smaller and larger,
based on where they are
in your
field of view.
Things are bigger
in the center,
and they shrink
as they go away.
We've played
with the aspect-oriented--
which picture to choose.
And we've had hyperlinks between
the text and the 3-D world.
We think with the new
JavaScript API for Google Earth,
that that might be
a great way
to create
at least the basics of this.
And then work through
how we're going to implement
some of these
other features on top
of what exists
in the current KML.
I think we can do a lot.
But we have yet to figure out
what that might look like.
There's a lot we can do,
and we're going
to try a few things
in the next couple months.
But we look forward to feedback
on that first prototype,
to see what might be
a good match for people,
without loading the interface
with too many things.
Now I'd like
to show you something
in our actual in-the-field
implementation of stuff.
This is a project that's
just going online right now.
The Right Whale AIS project
aims to notify mariners,
without any effort
on their part,
of where right whales
might be in critical habitats.
The right whales
on the east coast--
they were down
to about 350 right whales.
So we'd like to give
the mariners as much tools
as possible to avoid
running into these whales.
Or if it's impossible to know
that the whale's there,
to at least
be going slow enough
that any impact with a whale
might not be fast enough
to actually harm the animal
enough to kill it.
So to give you a sense of what's
going on in the Boston area,
here's a figure
to give you a view
of a couple of types of ships
and how they use the waterway.
Some ships, such as fishing,
or tugs, or research vessels--
they're the worst--
don't really work in a very nice
easy-to-work-with manner.
However, that cargo and
liquefied natural gas carriers
tend to really run
a very consistent line.
They use the traffic lanes
very consistently.
And as a part
of a new deep-water port
that's being put in here
for LNG, right off the coast,
the coast guard, NOAA
and the local
natural gas companies
have agreed
to spend money
to put in buoys all along this
to let mariners know
when whales have been hurt
in a particular area.
So let me show you
the first implementation
of this user interface
for the mariners.
We did it in Google Earth.
It was the easiest tool
to create an interface
that we found.
And what we have is a circle
for each of our buoys.
And when that buoy
detects a right whale call,
it goes back to mission control
at Cornell university.
They verify a whale,
and the little ring
on the screen turns yellow,
letting the mariner know
that there was a whale there
sometime in the last 24 hours.
This way, mariners can
use their best judgment
to understand what to do,
or if your the LNG carrier,
you're actually required
by your contracts
with the coastguard
to go less than 10 knots.
Now that we have those kinds
of things in place,
we also need to start working
on our background data.
And we've been looking
at how to deal
with multibeam data
with Google Earth,
so we can have rapid turnaround
of validation of our tools,
without having to deal
with the multi-day process
of pressing
with the high-powered tools
such as CARIS.
Here's an example
of a really unusual system,
and how easy it is to drop
into Google Earth.
I used a combination
of MB-System and Google Earth
to drop in the track lines,
make sure that this wave rider,
which is a little jet ski-like
device with a SONAR on it--
driven by Tom Lipman,
of our institution--
to actually go in
and quick make a model of this.
...
...into Google Earth.
...go through all the stuff
we're trying to deal
with a whole bunch
of research papers
that are focused
on various waterways
and the bottom of the ocean,
things like that.
We have a request of Google.
We would love to see--
instead of just Google Scholar--
"Google Spatial Scholar."
So we've actually done a quick
prototype of what it might be
to lay in the historic data.
We had a whole
team of graduate students,
who came up
with these projects,
and they
took old multibeam data,
their figures and papers,
and laid it on Google Earth
where those figures should go.
And maybe in the end result,
you really want these things
glued right on the planet
where they're supposed to be.
But this shows the idea of being
able to take a database
such as EndNote,
and export a KML,
and be able to just spin
around the globe,
and see where
the papers are.
So if you're interested
in Hawaii, you fly into Hawaii,
and you just
get the Hawaii papers.
Now I'd like to finish up
with an example of a tool
that's--that's
about to come online.
It'll be a little bit longer
than the whale system.
This is nowCOAST,
done by NOAA.
And they've worked with the
University of New Hampshire
to create a tool
called FloVis,
and get it on the web.
This is an ArcIMS interface.
So if you go to nowCOAST,
this will be there
hopefully
in the next month or two.
And we've worked
on visualization techniques
that actually are based
on the human visual system.
So this sort
of "Starry Night" view
is the current velocities
along the U.S. east coast.
You can see the Gulf Stream
nice and clear.
As we were working on this,
we thought...
What if we did it in Google?
What if it was
right on the globe,
And we weren't
always in ArcIMS?
So we've taken
a quick look at that,
and it looks
really promising.
Here, I used Fledermaus
to go in and drop
a geoTIFF onto Google Earth.
And the results
are really quite stunning.
Being able to fly around
and really see
this kind of flow model
is fantastic.
This is something when
I had to take Oceanography
as a grad student,
I would've killed
for this visualization.
I still don't totally
understand flow visualization,
and I'm not an Oceanographer.
I'm a marine geologist,
and geophysicist.
But it's really great
to see this stuff,
and understand
the context of my geology
within the currents
of the area.
So, thank you all for listening.
If you have any more interest
in this type stuff,
my blog at Schwehr.org
has a lot more pictures
of all this stuff,
and you can download
some of the files.
Thank you for listening.
[applause]
Any questions?
Yes.
man: [indistinct]
Schwehr: Can you repeat
the question?
man: [indistinct]
Schwehr: We would rather have
Google do that than us, yes.
It would be great
to have a street-view car,
that we plunk on top of a ship,
and drive around the harbor.
We're in a way emulating that,
except for one aspect.
In street view,
you want to show everything,
because people are interested in
all sorts of different features.
Here, we have a community
that actually wants you
to go in
and decimate the data,
and just find
those key features.
So when they're coming
into a harbor,
they don't want to know every
nook and cranny of the harbor,
they want to know the key
lighthouses, the buildings,
the features they need
to go to where they're going.
So they're going
to aim for that lighthouse,
take a left at the third pier
and head for home.
And it may be foggy and dark.
So they want
to have that best knowledge
without all of the street view
like stuff in there.
So we have an
extra decimation problem.
Yes?
Next question.
man: [indistinct]
Schwehr: nowCOAST?
Schwehr: That one?
man: [indistinct]
Schwehr: Before the whales.
Schwehr: That one, yes.
man: [indistinct]
Schwehr: This is not
Google Earth.
This is our in-house OpenGL
implementation.
And we hope to have
a Google Earth implementation.
We have a couple different teams
taking their own take on it.
We have one in Florida.
man: [indistinct]
Schwehr: We've looked at
photo overlays, and we think
that might be a way to go.
We have some questions on
how to control the image use,
to maybe do
something like the multirama.
We think we might be able
to pull that out
with sort of a, you know, level
detail region-type feature
where you pick
which region,
and it's not true
level of detail.
So perhaps
those kinds of things.
But this is
not currently Google Earth.
I wish it was.
But it's not.
Any more questions?
Thank you.
[applause]
And I didn't Photoshop that.